- Who is a survivor?
They're all survivors.
We're about to look at
the worst medical injuries
and emergencies that went
down on the show "Survivor".
Gotta give a huge thank you to ButcherBox
for sponsoring this video.
Stay tuned to find out how you can get
two free filet mignons and
$15 off your first box.
Be-woop!
- I'm a little dizzy.
- What's happening?
- First bit of movement from Lauren,
just a slight adjustment.
What's happening?
- [Jeff] Trying to keep
from going numb, probably.
- She's about to pass out.
- I can't see anything.
I'm about to black out.
- Whoa!
- She dropped, medical!
(contestants exclaim)
- Why do you wait to run over?
She announced it.
- [Woman] Oh my god.
- God, what happened?
- Lauren passed out, just keep going.
- Just keep going. (laughs)
- [Man] She's got people around her, Vic.
- [Woman] She's okay.
- Yeah, so this is probably
a vasovagal reaction,
where not enough circulations
going to her brain.
She's probably gonna come to real quick.
- [Medic] Hey Lauren, you just fainted.
- Yep.
- Damn it.
(Dr. Mike laughs)
- She's like ah, I didn't
get the golden buzzer.
Whatever they have on this show.
- [Sam] Immunity idol.
- Yesterday, a piece of sand got in my eye
and I guess I scratched my eye.
- Aw, corneal abrasion is so painful.
The cornea has some of
the most nerve fibers
in the entire human
body, concentration wise.
Tearing, visual difficulties, pain.
Pain, pain, pain.
- It got swollen and I
couldn't sleep at night.
- Oh, that's an infection.
My man needs antibiotics.
- [Medic] The first thing I'm gonna do
is try and have a look inside your eye.
- So the way that we do this in order
to do an exam for a corneal abrasion
is we put a fluorescent stain,
it's a little thing on
the edge of the eye.
It puts a stain in, you just
have to be really careful
'cause it could permanently
stain contact and clothes
and then we either use a
woods lamp to light up the eye
or pen with a blue filter or a proper way
to do it as a slit lamp exam.
You could see if there's
any corneal abrasions there
based on where the deposits
of the fluorescent stain go.
- What I need to rule out
is that he hasn't gotten
an abrasion or an
abnormality on his cornea
which is the clear part
that covers his eye.
So the only way to do that
is to put in an orange dye
and I'm able to see things more clearly.
- Okay.
- Okay, so that's a fluorescent strip.
Basically, when you put
it at the edge of the eye,
it makes the eye really orange and yellow.
- It actually looks like there is
what I would call a divot in this cornea.
- Oh, that's a problem.
- Is there something we can do out here?
- No.
- Unfortunately not.
- Antibiotics, anti-inflammatories.
(man screams)
- [Woman] Water, get him
some water!
- [Man] Are you okay?
(man shouts)
- Oh, what happened?
- [Woman] Oh my God.
- He burned, he's burned pretty bad.
- He burned?
How did he burn himself?
Oh.
- [Man] He passed out
and fell in the fire.
- [Woman] He passed out into the fire.
- [Man] Stay in the
water, stay in the water.
- He fell into the fire?
- I was blowing on the fire
and the smoke was right my face
and I inhaled and I passed out.
- There must have been
some toxic fumes there
'cause smoke inhalation
for a short period of time
is rarely strong enough to
cause you to pass out instantly.
The only way that could
happen is there's some kind of
chemical process going on,
like something burning,
causing a poison sensation.
When you're around a fire,
there's a few things that
can happen that could cause
you to not get enough oxygen.
A, fire essentially burns
and eats up off that oxygen
so it can cause you to asphyxiate.
Also when you're burning something,
you naturally create carbon monoxide,
which when you inhale, actually
binds with the hemoglobin
in your blood, which
normally carries oxygen
and competes with the oxygen
that you're also inhaling
to bind to that hemoglobin,
forming carboxyhemoglobin
and then that circulates
through your body,
not giving your tissues
the oxygen that it needs
and as a result, you can die
from carbon monoxide poisoning.
We've seen that time and time again
and the way to reverse
that is by giving a patient
a ton of oxygen to sort of
out-compete that carbon monoxide
that is already floating
around in the blood
trying to bind to the hemoglobin.
Another thing obviously that could happen
is a chemical burn of your trachea
and that's really problematic.
You need a breathing tube for that.
(woman exclaims)
- Oh!
- I can't decide whether I should keep
trying to bend them or not.
- Okay, so burning of the
hands is a very big problem.
I mean obviously a lot of
nerve fibers on your fingers
and hands in order for you
to feel the world around you.
As a result, that means
it's gonna hurt a ton more
and then on top of it,
because of the way burns heal
on this area specifically,
you form contractures.
So you're usually gonna
need multiple surgeries
or procedures to keep those
contractures from forming.
- I'll take whatever you give me,
I'll take the pain without drugs,
I'll do whatever you guys say.
Breathe?
- [Medic] When you breathe...
- Oh look, that's the pen.
That's the pen we saw in Bondi Beach.
How did they do this
before we had pain control?
That's all I think about.
- I'm actually worried.
I'm not sure, but I think
I got a bug in my ear.
- Aw, that's why we have ear wax.
- Instead of crawling out, it
is getting deeper in my ear.
- Well it's not getting deeper.
There's no real place for it to go.
It's not gonna crawl into
your eustachian tube.
- I can't sleep, I can't get comfortable.
It's just disgusting, hearing
these little legs crawl
around in your head.
- Did it lay eggs in her ear?
- It's coming out, it's coming out.
There it is, there it is.
- That little thingy?
- [Man] I think it's out of
your ear, I think it worked.
- What is that little thing?
It's like a little worm.
It's like a miniature salmonella...
(laughs) salmonella, salamander.
Back to the show in just a second.
But first I want to talk
to you about ButcherBox.
One of the hardest parts of trying
to survive on a deserted island
would be the drastic change in your diet.
But thanks to ButcherBox,
I have no trouble
getting my hands on fresh,
high-quality meat and fish.
As some of you know,
this last year, I have
completely transformed my
diet, ahead of my boxing debut.
Undefeated, by the way,
which means I got to enjoy
a ton of ButcherBox free
range USDA-certified
organic chicken and wild-caught seafood.
ButcherBox delivers incredible
meat and fish directly to my door.
Thanks to them, I can
trust the high quality
meat and fish I put on my table each day.
It's better for me, the farmers,
the animals welfare and
ultimately, our planet.
In particular, I've
been enjoying their wild
Alaskan Sockeye salmon,
which is fresh and flavorful
while also being packed full of nutrients.
One of the best parts is you can choose
your box and delivery frequency
so you get exactly the foods
you and your family love,
all in an eco-friendly,
100% recyclable box
and if you sign up right now, ButcherBox
is gonna give you two
free fileting mignons
and $15 off your first box,
not to mention that
shipping is always free.
All right, let's get back to the show.
- Beauty pulls it out!
Second place finish reward for Beauty.
Nothing for Brawn but an empty,
lonely afternoon back at camp.
- They look hot and
dry and I point out dry
specifically because if you
are in a hot environment
and you're not sweating, that tells me
that you're potentially
susceptible to heat stroke.
- [Woman] Whew.
Caleb, water?
- Did we just predict
a little suh'n suh'n?
- [Medic] Move out, move out, move out.
- Okay, so heat stroke
is really dangerous,
especially in environments like this
because you lose the ability to cool off.
See, your natural temperature
is set by your brain,
apart of your brain
called the hypothalamus
and it usually sets your temperature
to around 98 degrees Fahrenheit,
98.6 is the typical norm that we use
but it does fluctuate a degree or two.
When you are in this
position, your temperature
starts going up and not
because of your hypothalamus
and you lose the ability to cool yourself,
likely because you're
dehydrated, likely because
you've tried to sweat and
it's been inefficient.
So as a result, your
organs can start failing,
your brain can stop functioning,
you can go into a coma.
Heat stroke is one of the
deadliest parts of being outdoors
and usually it's accentuated by activity,
so strenuous activity, like
being on the show "Survivor".
- All right dude, we
got some water coming.
Hang in there, all right?
- The first thing you'd want
to do is obviously give water.
With water, you're able to
sweat and when you're sweating,
you can evaporate that liquid
and then as a result, cool your body off.
'Cause you remember,
when evaporation occurs,
the surface of the skin does cool down.
- [Medic] Everybody back up.
- Oh, which is what they're doing.
- Hey buddy, you're in really good hands.
- I want someone to do some vitals on him.
Check his vitals, I need to know
what his pulse is, what
his blood pressure is.
I need to know if he's
neurologically intact.
- So Joe, you're giving him
fluids to rehydrate and what?
- We're gonna give Caleb
some cold intravenous fluids
to try and bring his temperature down.
- Fluids internally that are cold
will actually speed up
the cooling process.
Now something we do with patients,
whenever we cool them down
with a solution like that
or spraying them with cold water,
the body's natural reaction
sometimes is to shiver,
which increases the temperature
and this is not a time
you want that to happen.
So we would actually give a
patient the muscle relaxer,
like a benzodiazepine
to help calm them down
to decrease that shiver response
in order to allow us to cool them down.
- Caleb, you know there's only
two ways you leave this game
other than being voted
out and that's quitting,
which you clearly are not doing
and that is a doctor
saying they are too worried
about you to let you continue.
You don't want to be pulled.
Buddy, you don't have a choice.
- Yeah.
- [Jeff] It's a doctor's call.
- Yeah, you don't wanna
mess around with this
'cause permanent brain
damage is not something
you want to be a contestant on "Survivor".
- Okay.
- Yeah, Mount St. Neil actually
blew its lid this afternoon.
Huge chunk of pus came out and then
there's something even grosser on my back.
- Okay, that doesn't look good.
It looks like some kind of animal bite.
There's some kind of necrosis
happening there, the black tissue.
- I mean, I'm looking to see
what it could potentially become
and that one is in the
skin, but there's nothing
under there I think will
immediately be damaged.
- So assessment on this is what?
- It's a big, nasty spot.
- Abcess?
He said it's "a big, nasty spot"?
Is "big, nasty spot" a
medical diagnosis these days?
Yeah, I don't know what
that is and it's definitely
not life threatening in the
moment but in the jungle,
I would love to know what
could have caused it.
This person obviously
knows way more than me
- And being close to
a joint like the knee,
is that more serious?
- Correct.
- Having an infection
near the knee puts you
at a higher risk for septic arthritis,
which is an infection of the joint
or an osteomyelitis, which
is an infection of the bone.
Both of those are quite serious
and require IV antibiotics.
Is his wound that bad?
The front one doesn't look terrible.,
It just looks like
there's some tissue there
that's forming to create sort
of the next layer of healing.
What you wanna look for is
the tissue surrounding it.
Is the redness starting to spread?
Is there streaking happening?
Some fluctuance below the
wound, basically signs
of the cellulitis is
what you're looking for.
I didn't see that on that initial look.
Migraine?
Nightmare?
Back pain from sleeping on the floor?
- I think it's an
emergency, it's really bad.
- Bruce had really horrible stomach pains.
He's had pains for about four days now
and it just got really unbearable for him.
- The worry here is appendicitis.
Obviously that's a surgical emergency.
Colitis would be a big problem too.
You're gonna need antibiotics for that.
- [Medic] And I'm gonna
assess you first before I can
start giving you any treatment.
- That's really important
with abdominal pain,
that you don't give
pain medicine too early
in the treatment before you examine
because you might not
know what's going on.
- [Man] Don't, don't, don't.
- The areas where he's pushing
looks like it's an appendicitis.
Technically appendicitis starts
on the right lower quadrant
but there's been stories
of patients having it
in the center of their abdomen,
then migrating to the
right lower quadrant.
Some people having contralateral
pain on the opposite side.
So there's never a clear
answer with appendicitis.
Especially, it depends on where in
the course of the
appendicitis that you are.
Early stages, late
stages, has it perforated,
now it's spreading through
your entire abdomen?
- [Medic] I can't rule out
that it's not his appendix.
- [Man] Sure.
- Point is,
we're gonna take him.
- Getting transported like
that with an appendicitis
would be so painful because
any kind of jiggling
of the abdomen, of an acute
abdomen, is so painful.
That's why one of the
special tests we use is
we have a patient jump
on their heels to see
if there is a truly acute abdomen.
They'll tell you right away,
they'll scream and tell you it's terrible.
- They ran some tests and found out
that his entire digestive system,
his colon and his bladder were blocked.
Nothing was coming out.
- What?
Are they saying he was constipated?
Something doesn't make sense.
He had such bad constipation
that it was also blocking his bladder?
Because the colon runs from here, across,
up and then down and then
becomes the small intestine.
The bladder's down here in the pubic area.
The only thing that it could be,
a (stutters) vesiculocolinic fistula.
Where if you have a passageway in between,
created between the colon and the bladder,
where feces can actually
travel into the bladder,
causing an infection and a blockage.
- I can't feel my hands.
- Why can't she feel her hands?
- All right, you're all
right, you're all right.
I'm right here with you.
- You doing all right?
- I can't tell if I'm
panicking or dehydrated.
- Hey medical, Dr. Joe.
- Dr. Joe, Dr. Mike,
we're all first name here.
- My arms are cramping up.
- [Medic] That's because you're breathing
a little bit quickly, all right?
- What's wrong with Hannah?
- I don't know.
- You're not gonna let me die?
- Of course not.
- (laughs) "You're not gonna let me die."
I love that, he's God.
He controls who lives and dies.
- [Medic] This is just
because you're breathing
a little bit quick, Hannah.
- So if you breathe out too quickly,
you can actually create an
oxygen carbon dioxide imbalance,
sort of over blow off carbon
dioxide and as a result,
cause an acid base imbalance
in your bloodstream.
- I knew coming out
here that panic attacks
are something that I'm prone to
but I just didn't wanna
be one of those people.
- Well, panic attacks can
make the situation worse
because during a panic attack,
you feel tightness of the chest,
you start getting anxious.
When you're hyperventilating,
you release too much carbon dioxide
and when you release carbon dioxide,
which acts as an acid in your blood,
you actually shift that
to have your blood become
a higher pH, which makes it more basic.
That's why people say breathe into a bag
because then you re-inhale
some of that carbon dioxide.
- [Sam] Oh, really?
That's where the bag thing is from?
- Yeah.
Here's a list of 10 foods
that can actually kill you.
Click here to check that out and remember,
if you sign up to ButcherBox right now,
you're gonna get two free filet mignons
and $15 off your first box.
As always, stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat music begins)